[Music]
right welcome to mexico we are in the
gorgeous oaxaca and let me tell you i've
learned more on these last week
in oaxaca than aron sanchez has taught
me about mexican cuisine the last 10
years because this is the real deal i've
got up to speed with an amazing molly
i've got up to speed with a beautiful
tortilla i've got up to speed with
incredible taco and i'm going to show
you a
a sort of street food phenomenon that's
equivalent to
our
street food pizza back at home it starts
off with this beautiful base of this
stunning
baked tortilla i'm going to turn this
into a delicious snack
called
tillauda
now
get that nice and hot first okay spread
the oil on there
a little bit of pork fat
and just start melting that on there
that's gonna give that tortilla
the most amazing flavor
season that okay now once that pork fat
starts to melt
that flavor
is incredible
okay
look at that
generous
on that oil
okay
from there get that beautiful tortilla
on there okay
that starts getting crispy now from
there
take your black bean paste
and just
place that into the middle now
beautifully spread that
all the way around
now go all the way to the very end use
the back of the spoon get that nice and
thin keep it nice and thin it stops the
tortilla from going soggy
from there get some of your oaxacan
cheese this is a beautiful
stringy cheese and just open it up
and just place that on there
look pull that apart
and there you go
this is beautiful now from there give
that again
a little season
a little bit of pepper
a little bit of salt avocados
and just literally
slice them in half
get your spoon
and just get inside
and scoop that out nicely
beautiful
let's be generous on the avocado
and then from there look
lightly season those avocado
and just slice them
nice and then go through
and just drop them off lift and drop
them on the tortilla stay nice and
crispy beautiful cheese is melting
now
from there
get these beautiful tomatoes
and that's going to give it a little bit
of sweetness
look at these
beautiful
and then place these tomatoes around
there
now
look at that you can see how we're
starting to put those layers with that
nice sweetness from the tomatoes take a
little bit of crema this is just
basically
almost like a nice sour cream
here i'm not drizzle that round
on top
off with the gas
slide that forward
now
you could pop that in the oven for two
minutes and melt it and caramelize the
top part the bean puree has got that
nice dense rich puree the sweetness of
the tomato but
we're not finished
we're in oaxaca
these are crickets this is a big staple
here and so we're gonna sort of drop
these beautiful
roasted crickets on top
and look at that
that screams
oaxaca
street food be generous in those
crickets they give a really nice sort of
nutty crunchy flavor
and then of course finally
a cilantro
and there you have it my friend
and that is a delicious
beautiful street food for mum aron
sanchez
eat your heart out my son now if you
enjoyed that recipe please click the
link below and if you missed uncharted
then please watch on catch up on disney
plus
[Music]